would you have ever killed someone for
your
beliefs
um yes um I uh especially as a as a
young Neo-Nazi I I was begging for War I
thought um I believed in the word from
old neo-nazis in the '90s I met up with
a lot of neo-nazis who uh Nazis who who
were still in the in the war fighting
for Germany like in the Wes s or in the
ver
and um they had like slogans like saying
um every generation needs a war to like
to like harden up and uh and um yeah I
would have um I would have killed for my
beliefs um in a war and um and then
uh I I did not have thoughts on going
just out on the streets and just
stubbing people down or shooting
anything um I I I always thought that
would just change nothing